mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a square is divided into five rectangles
these five rectangles have equal areas
if the orange rectangle has a width
equal to 4
what is the area of the entire square
i thank suryadi from indonesia for the
suggestion
and i believe the problem traces to a
puzzle posted on twitter by at
seashare41
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there are many ways to solve the problem
and i will present one method
suppose the upper left rectangle has a
length equal to a
then the area of the rectangle is equal
to four times a
as the rectangles all have equal areas
each rectangle has an area equal to four
a now suppose the remaining length on
the side of the square is equal to b
which is the length of this rectangle
then consider the area of this rectangle
composed of these three rectangles
one way to compute the area is that its
area will be equal to a times b
another way to compute the area is to
sum up the individual rectangles
this will have a total area equal to 12a
if we divide both sides by a we get that
b is equal to 12.
we thus put b is equal to 12 in our
diagram and we can see the side of the
square has a length equal to 16.
thus the area of the square is equal to
16 squared and that is equal to 256
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you